Is there a border we will never cross?
Are there places we will never reach?
No matter how hard we try?
Turns out there are even with science fiction technology,
we are trapped in our pocket of the universe.
How can that be and how far can we go?
We live in a quiet home of the Milky Way,
a spiral galaxy of average size about 100,000 light years across consisting of
billions of stars,
gas clouds,
dark matter,
black holes and neutron stars,
cabinets with a supermassive black hole in the galactic center.
From Afar,
our galaxy seems dance,
but in reality it consists mostly of empty space.
With our current technology,
sending a human to the closest star would take thousands of years,
so our galaxy is pretty big.
The Milky Way is not alone though along with the Andromeda galaxy and more than
50 Dorf galaxies.
It's part of the local group,
a region of space,
about 10 million light years in diameter.
It is one of hundreds of galaxy groups in the linear care supercluster,
which itself is only one of millions of superclusters that make up the
observable universe.
Now let's assume for a moment that we have a glorious future.
She mentee becomes a type three civilization,
does not get wiped out by aliens and develops the interstellar travel.
Based on our current understanding of physics and this best case scenario,
how far could we possibly go?
Well,
the local group,
it is the biggest structure that humanity will ever be a part of.
Why it is certainly huge.
The local group accounts for only zero point 0000000000 1% of the observable
universe net,
there's number sink in for a moment.
We are limited to $100 billion for the percent of the observable universe.
The simple fact that there is actually a limit for us and that there is so much
universe that we will never be able to touch.
It's kind of frightening
white coat.
We go further.
Well,
it all has to do with the nature of nothing.
Nothing or empty space isn't empty but has energy intrinsic to itself so called
quantum fluctuations.
On the smallest scale,
there is constant action particles and antiparticles appearing and annihilating
themselves.
You can imagine this quantum vacuum as a bubbling pot with dancer and less dense
regions.
Now,
let's go back 13.8 billion years when the fabric of space consisted of nothing
at all,
right after the big bang in an event known as cosmic inflation,
the observable universe expanded from the size of a marble to trillions of
kilometers in fractions of a second.
This sudden stretching of the universe was so fast and extreme that all those
quantum fluctuations were stretched as well,
and Subatomic distances became galactic distances with dense and less dense
regions.
After inflation,
gravity began to pull everything back together.
At the largest scale.
The expansion was too quick and powerful to overcome,
but at smaller scales,
gravity emerged victorious.
So overtime,
the denser regions or pockets of the universe grew into groups of galaxies like
the one we live in today.
Only stuff inside our pocket.
The local group is bound to us gravitation,
but wait,
what's the problem then?
Why can't we travel from our pocket to the next one here?
Dark energy makes everything complicated.
About 6 billion years ago,
dark energy took over.
It's basically an invisible force or effect that causes and speeds up the
expansion of the universe.
We don't know why or what dark energy is,
but we can observe its effect.
Clearly in the early universe,
they were larger cold spots around the local group that grew into large clusters
with thousands of galaxies.
We are surrounded by a lot of stuff,
but none of those structures and galaxies outside of the local group are
gravitation be bound to us.
So the more the universe expands,
the larger the distance between us and other gravitational pockets becomes over
time,
dark energy,
and we'll push the rest of the universal way from us causing all the other
classes,
galaxies,
and groups to eventually become unreachable.
The next galaxy group is already millions of light years away,
but all of them are moving away from us at speeds.
We can't ever hope to match.
We could leave the local group and fly through intergalactic space into the
darkness,
but we would never arrive anywhere.
While we will become more and more stranded,
the local group will become more tightly bound and merged together to form one
giant elliptical galaxy.
With the unoriginal name milk durometer in a few billion years,
but it becomes even more depressing.
At some point,
the galaxies outside the local group will be so far away that they will be too
faint to tact and the few photons that do make it to us,
we'll be shifted to such long wave lengths that there'll be undetectable.
Once this happens,
no information outside of the local group will be able to reach us.
The universe will recede from view.
It will appear to be a dark and empty in all directions forever of being born.
In the far future in milk.
Dramator will think there is nothing but its own galaxy in the entire universe.
When they look far into empty space,
they will only see more emptiness and darkness.
They won't be able to see cosmic background radiation and they won't be able to
learn about the big bang.
They will have no way of knowing what we know today.
The nature of the expanding universe when it began and how it will add.
They will think the universe is static and a turtle milk durometer will be an
island in the darkness.
Slowly getting darker and darker still with it's trillion stars.
The local group is certainly large enough for humanity.
After all,
we still haven't figured out how to leave our solar system and we have billions
of years to explore our galaxy.
We have the incredible luck to exist at the perfect moment in time to see not
only our future but also our most distant past as isolated and remote as the
local group is.
We can perceive the entire universe grand and spectacular as it is right now.
This video was sponsored by squarespace.com/nutshell.
Do you feel isolated in a humongous universe?
Why not set up a website or blog and share your thoughts with other humanoids
around you?
Squarespace lets you do that with easy to understand tools very quickly and
without any knowledge of Web design.
You can use the code nutshell to save 10% and support cuts because out in making
more videos about our place in the universe.
Thanks so much for the help with the video to Ethan Segal.
Checkout his astronomy blog hair.
You can support us directly at Patrion or get quotes cause onto merge here.
It really helps.
It's awesome that you watched this far.
So we've made a playlist for you about more universe stuff.